what you do after the game last night uh
we had a little uh adult beverages in
the suite nice and kind of hung out with
boys club who's in the club well let's
see let's see John Cusack was a Cubs
groupies convention Bill Murray John
Cusack any better Chris Chelios who and
then Sean Casey with the MLB Network the
loud guy who played 15 years in the show
I think end up with 100 home runs we
love the mayor who was em being who was
MVP who was closer last night you know
what I did the Irish goodbye with Mark
DeRosa because you can't say goodbye
because what you'll get is like come on
bro you're not going come on bro so you
just can't just sneak out so me and
gerosa or the early mmm Exeter's but I
tell you right now they are ready for
game 7 how knowledgeable is Eddie Vetter
you know their fans they love the game
um and I think he's been around feel
enough to he understands what's going on
a lot more than you think but I tell you
right I'll tell you one thing right now
Danny he's the most sincere normal human
being for the level that he's at and
then Bill Murray walks in and then Bill
Murray Bill Murray was hilarious he was
used for rows behind us uh in stands and
absolutely haggling Mark DeRosa because
he played for the Indians for three
months and DeRosa play for the Cubs so
it was constant just extremely young in
front where's your two jackets you know
and gerosa it was hilarious like Bill
Murray hates me let me get to the game
itself Game six the Cubs have the big
lead and so seventh inning Chapman comes
in at the time John Smoltz didn't agree
with that move by Joe Maddon what did
you think yeah didn't think so I didn't
like it either don't reason was because
you understand you have a six run lead
our five run lead or whatever it was
that that exact mo
and you're trying to say bullets because
game seven I think anything goes and so
I understand he only threw 20 pitches
but at the time you like it was a just a
tick early and maybe a tick unnecessary
but then you look at it from the other
side of Jill band size that we have to
win tonight if we don't win tonight and
you know a base runner here baseman are
there then you got three run bomb well
there's no the ball anyway so it can go
either way my opinion I would have
thrown them houses set up tonight well
you're going to see everybody in there
obviously you're gonna got the perfect
game for the cubs Kyle Hendricks throws
Jon Lester probably gets in any a clean
inning and then you know what you can
hand the ball to Chapman again the
underrated aspect of this is one if
clear we're going to beat the Cubs three
times in 10 days Kyle Hendricks no one
even talks about him is the best picture
internationally all season long so I
think I have a great game I think Kluber
has a chance to win you know obviously
has a chance but i'll tell you right now
he didn't throw great in Game two and
the Cubs missed a lot of pitches Game
one he was like out he's now at home in
his play well at home it's gonna be a
heck of a game if Kluber wins Kluber is
your MVP no doubt about a hand down I
mean hands down what about a penny with
one last night I think he's our MVP what
about the Cubs is it still left to be
written who'd be be MVP yeah it's a
tough one right me Addison Russell steps
up and drives in six mmm you know
immediately last night Baez was the hot
commodity in postseason that we all were
talking about what rocket called Kris
Bryant me Chapman how do you what are
you starting if Jon Lester has been
amazing one of these fan base is going
to lose that's the amazing part though
when you it had to go to a seventh game
it's just but but also one of these fan
bases does win you're right III think
you know and I was asked you know which
which fan base has the most pressure I
think right now obviously it's it's
Cubs uh even though it's the business
fun silly goose you know lovable losers
but I still think that 100 years 108
years of just they haven't won in
Cleveland being 70 plus the Cubs are
just dying for this so it's going to be
I mean it's gonna be everything you want
we shall have had that big moment though
you know I'm waiting for the big moment
you know you're down by three three run
home run you tie it you go by one the
next team goes down by one we haven't
had that it's usually the team that
leads and gets out with the lead whims
baseball could have scripted this any
better no i'ma tell you right now they
really could and it would have been
really odd opinions would have won three
straight in Chicago and won it in Game
five but here you are game six Cubs
explode authentically miscue in the
outfield in center field you know they
score 3 in the 1st and next thing you
know they're off and running now you
have clue bruh Kyle Hendricks to the
best pictures out there get some rest
keep on rockin in the free world Danny
Patrick always good to talk to you buddy
all right slugger we'll talk to you soon
we'll see you buddy the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience